you've written a lot about law
enforcement and uh we're not enforcing
the law nope talk about that a little
bit uh what is the effect of not doing
that and then I'll ask you why are we
not doing that we've Unleashed Anarchy
Upon Our cities we are subjecting
business owners to predation we have
given up on the basic obligation of
civilization which is to protect
property I actually think that the
widespread looting that is going on in
many many American cities of on a daily
basis statistically it is known in New
York City every single day there will be
hundreds of business owners who are
stolen from and yet our mayor Eric Adams
concerns himself with other things as
far as I'm concerned when you know that
as a statistical truth that you are not
protecting those business owners
expectations s of security in their
property you have no right to exist as a
government that that is even more
shocking than the
violence it's strange to say because
obviously if you're the victim of a
violent
crime uh that is
lifechanging and is also a deprivation
of some of your basic rights but the
ongoing assault and insecurity of
property is really a unbelievably
corrosive and this is an absolutely
predictable result of the fact that we
have decided that to enforce the law in
a or it it's not that we decide it is
true it is a truth that if we enforce
the law in a neutral colorblind fashion
we will have a disperate impact on black
criminals not because the law and the
criminal justice system is racist not
because the police are racist or were
white supremacist but because the crime
rates are so much higher in the black
community and anybody who's looking
around today and saying what the heck is
going on with these Progressive
prosecutors it's Alvin brag in New York
or George gascone in Los Angeles or Kim
Fox in in Chicago Larry Kesner in
Philadelphia why aren't they why have
they decided to put off entire
categories of crime are entually
decriminalized so they're not going en
Force trespass or theft or Fair beating
resisting arrest if you don't understand
race you don't understand what's going
on it's all about race if there were no
racial disparities and criminal
offending our attitude would basically
be lock them up and throw away the key
nobody would be talking about mass
incarceration mass incarceration is a
euphemism for the fact that there are
racial disparities let me give you a
again facts that are not allowed in the
public sphere Dr Arn because the only
allowable explanation for any racial
disparity here's the rule is racism
you're not allowed to talk about
Behavior you're not allowed to talk
about skills when it comes to behavior
in the post George Floyd race riot era
black juveniles are shot at 100 times
the rate of white
juveniles blacks between the ages of 10
and 24 die of gun homicide and 24 times
the rate of whites in that same age
cohort who's killing them and who's
shooting them not the police not whites
but other blacks there is Carnage going
on on an unbelievable basis daily in
inner cities and the world and the Press
turns its eyes away because it's
terrified that it doesn't know how to
close those crime gaps you had a great
article more than one but you had a
great article
not too long ago about uh death rates by
cops in Primus our publication which
everybody can get if they want it uh can
you remember those numbers how many
people do cops kill in a year in America
well cops kill it's been been remarkably
stable ever since the Washington Post
started keeping track in
2015 which to me suggests that this is
not some arbitrary number it reflects
the degree to which cops interact with
violent armed and resisting suspects
because that's what predicts cop use of
lethal Force if you don't want to get
killed by a cop here's a simple thing do
not resist arrest so every year the cops
shoot fatally about a thousand
people a a little over half of those are
white so about 52 53 55% are white and
about 25 to 27% are
black so the black lives matter
activists Al Sharpton and the mainstream
media CNN MSNBC they get get their hands
on that 25% number and they say aha
racist criminal justice system because
blacks are 133% of the nation's
population so they're being shot at
about twice the rate that's the wrong
Benchmark the question is what is the
black crime rate and if you look at the
L 75 largest counties in the United
States which is where most of the
population resides blacks commit about
66% of all violent crime though they're
15% of the population in those counties
so that means that here in New York City
for example blacks are 22% of the
population they commit about 75% of all
driveby shootings whites are 34% they
commit 1 to 2% of all driveby shootings
add Hispanic shootings to Black
shootings you account for about 100% of
all shootings in New York City this has
enormous consequences for policing it
means that virtually every time the
police are called to shots fired called
meaning somebody been shot in one of
these grotesque barbaric driveby
shootings that have taken dozens of
black children's lives since George Floy
they are almost always being called to a
scene being given the description of a
black suspect if anybody is is
cooperating with them for once and the
victims are themselves black that
explains why blacks are shot more at a
higher rate here's the other comparison
though the police officer is forign 00
times as likely to be killed by a black
person as an unarmed black is to be
killed by a police officer so
Libertarians like Radley Balo always go
around saying oh policing is so safe you
know it's just beos it's just this
sickly trickly uh you know uh
sentimentality that says policing is
racist that doing a car felon car stop
is really a safe activity if it's safe
to be a police officer in America
it's really safe to be an unarmed black
Visa a police
officer so everything the public thinks
it knows about policing crime and race
from the mainstream media is a lie
reverse it and you have the
truth